[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici c'était le 12 juillet 2013 à
Saint-Paul tous les responsables de la
coopération agricole réonnaise s'était
réuni à cambé pour fêter la naissance
d'un beau bébé pet food run en cette fin
d'après-midi ensoleillé la première
usine réunionnaise de fabrication
d'aliments secs pour animaux de
compagnie était inaugurée officiellement
surous les
applaudissements cette usine n'aurait
pas vu le jour si elle ne s'était pas
inscrite dans cette ambition qui est
celle des coopératives et de l'urcopa à
la Réunion l'innovation a été au cœur du
projet je je le disais valoriser des
coproduits locaux dans des conditions de
fabrication les plus modernes et les
plus sûres en terme de qualité pour
satisfaire un marché local aujourd'hui
complètement dépendant des importations
c'est quand même un une réponse
formidable à la fois au
consommateurs réunionné et à l'économie
locale tout entière après les phases
d'essaiis de réglage des machines
indispensables l'usine est désormais
pleinement opérationnelle depuis
quelques mois maintenant les premiers
sacs de croquette pour chiens sont
produits et commercialisés sur le marché
local des croquettes pays fabriquées à
partir de céréales importées mais
également de coproduits de volaille
issus des abattoirs locaux et c'est un
des coproduits qu'on utilise pour
fabriquer la
groquette en l'occurence c'est quoi là
ça c'est la protéine de volaille il su
des abattoirs de Crête d'Or abattoir du
Cheman des abattoirs locaux ça c'est par
exemple c'est à base c'est des céréales
c'est du blé du maïs du riz produite
localement ou importé les matières
premières sont réceptionnées et stocké
dans ces silos en amont de la chaîne de
fabrication on a une dizaine
d'ingrédients en fait qui arrivent par
ici alors elles sont trois formes
différentes soit sous forme de vrac donc
là c'est les céréales en fait qui
représente 65 % à peu près la croquette
euh soit sous forme de de Big Bag en
fait notamment par exemple les protéines
animales de de volaille qui qui rentre
pour 25 % à peu près dans la dans la
formule et puis après sous forme de sac
également de 25 kg notamment euh et là
on trouve donc les oligoéléments les
vitamines et puis voilà les minéraux
tout à fait ces différents ingrédients
sont par la suite dosés et mélangés
selon le type de croquette à fabriquer
le dosage c'est simplement comme une
cuisine faut doser les ingrédients faut
mettre la quantité nécessaire faut peser
la quantité demandée pour fabriquer
chaque croquette l'étape suivante
consiste à cuire et à former les
croquettes en une seule opération on va
incorporer en fait avec la matière qui a
été mélangé près à la brement donc de la
vapeur et de l'eau et puis on va donc le
pousser avec de la pression
à travers une filière qui va avec une
forme particulière chaque roquette ayant
sa forme donné après la croquette par un
phénomène d'expansion on va obtenir la
croquette par la
[Musique]
suite implanté à Saint-Paul dans la zone
industrielle de cambé pet food run la
première usine de fabrication de
croquettes pour chiens et chats est
opérationnelle depuis le mois d'avril
dernier au cœur de l'unité le process et
les recettes sont à présent bien rodés
après leur sortie de l'extrudeur les
croquettes sont séchées puis enrobé
d'arôme et de graisse pour les rendre
plus appétissantes il ne reste plus
alors qu'à les conditionner en sac on se
positionne sur plusieurs segment du
marché donc il a y a en gros C segments
de de marché donc le premier prix
économique le standard plus le qualité
supérieure et le Premium et nous nous
positionnons donc sur l'économique le
standard plus et le le qualité
supérieure ce qui en fait correspond au
plus gros du marché c'est un produit qui
répond à toutes les les exigences du
marché et en même temps d'un point de
vue réglementaire également puisqu'on a
un agrément qui a été délivré par la par
les services vétérinaires donc qui nous
a permis de pouvoir fabriquer après les
croquettes mais avant le lancement de la
gamme de de croquett sur le marché
plusieurs phases de test ont également
permis d'élaborer ces aliments complets
de qualité pour chien la dernière phase
de test donc c'est sur un un panel de
chiens donc à la fois par des
particuliers qui étaient volontaires et
à la fois avec laasa notre partenaire
chez qui on a pu tester donc nos
croquettes notamment la pétence et que
tout se passe bien pour eux pendant
plusieurs
semaines pour nous le fait qu'il y ait
une usine sur l'île et quelque chose moi
je trouve de super hein c'était vu le
nombre d'animaux qu'il y a c'était
nécessaire on a été tout de suite
d'accord pour essayer les croquettes et
être partenaire de cette
opération un partenariat gagnant gagnant
pour la jeune entreprise saolloise et la
Société protectrice des animaux
effectivement ils ont mis sur les sacs
donc les coordonnées de la SPA et nos
coordonnées et en plus des des
d'adoption donc c'est remarquable pour
nous voilà d'avoir des croquettes
locales qui qui fassent la la publicité
de la SPA voilà passionné également de
chiens Fabrice Toulet possède qu à lui
de magnifique bordeur colis ce sont les
chiens qui encadrent en général les
troupeaux comme on voit comme Belle et
Sébastien voilà belle c'est c'est un
bordur colis elles se sont Varé assez
spécifique parce qu'elles ont le poil
un peu chiné mais ça reste border colis
à partir du moment où elles se dépensent
elles ont besoin d'énergie et donc pas
n'importe quoi comme
[Musique]
alimentation